our yeah our our uh
our ac chris
you know um
hits the clap stick and you hear you
hear our director claire claire scanlan
directed the last one and she's like um
you know um
it's like phil widen out you know to to
get like the wide
you know shot um
and
you know chris is he's like nine nine
forever slaps a stick
and
99 forever is that the only time he said
that that's the only time that was sad
yeah not forever and you know on a
clapstick on the slate and uh and
everyone's like here we go and so you
know we we've run we run it for a long
time we don't really um
we don't really uh cut a lot we're just
like rolling and rolling and rolling so
we knew this is it like before the cut
before you're cut
that's what you would hear
that's how they would do it right and uh
i just blow your ears out sorry um that
uh we knew th this was going to be it so
anyway um
uh that happens
you know we do hear cut there's this big
uh big exhale and roar and clap and
applause and
hugs
um but quick hugs because it's coveted
um
hugs with six foot long arms right and
um we all go outside
you know um because there's going to be
a nice um
there's a podium out there and everyone
is six feet apart and listening to
our
dp rick page and our creator dan gore
and uh just say a few words and then
the thing i was most not prepared for
was uh
you know when they wrap you out as an
actor
and you're they're just going up the
call sheet you know and they're like
joel mckinnon miller that's a that's a
series rap on joel mckinley miller and
everyone's just like oh no oh and i i
was just not i couldn't keep it together
once it got to me
you know you were gone oh i was i lost
it i was just like you know you hear
your name
you know said for the last time on a
show that has
brought so much you know
wealth and joy wealth i say that
financially and
emotionally and spiritually to your life
that
and that you're so grateful you're just
filled with this gratitude and you can't
believe it's over
um and you know you're gonna still be in
touch with um with everyone but it'll be
different you know or you know we're not
gonna see each other every day and all
of that heaviness all that truth is just
coming down it's just raining on you
like oh you're like just got to you're
just trying so you really lost it you're
crying you're like really crying yeah
absolutely yeah were there anyone who it
was like it was sandberg emotional
everyone wasn't everyone there wasn't
one person who was kind of stoic
everyone who was happy that it was
[ __ ] over maybe andre brauer
[Laughter]
he was like yes
no
no yeah
no everyone everyone in their own way
like you could read their eyes like it
wasn't all tears but by body language or
just their look or how i mean every
everyone you felt
knew the magnitude of the end and what
was really nice is that you know after
that happened
a few of us
put our mask back on and we went into
the bullpen for the last time and we
went out on the kind of rooftop
the fake rooftop out there and just
reminisced a little bit in a quieter um
area you know it wasn't the everyone it
was just the cast and a couple of the
writers
and we just talked about uh
you know favorite episodes and memories
and it was a beautiful end and we
finally left around
10 p.m where
we knew
that you walked off the set and then
that was it the pneumatic drills were
going to be heard in the morning
though everything was coming down apart
taking it apart it was all gonna go down
you're looking at it for the last time
and you're just like wow this place is
forever in my head
and
i hope that all the moments
that i had over the past eight years are
in a secure place up in the up in the
noggin that i can remember because this
is it all this tangible
stuff that goes away tomorrow morning
and that's it and it was intense man did
you cry to your wife
oh my god i came home
and i
literally collapsed into beth's arms and
like
literally hitch sobbed like oh
just got it i was like it was out yeah
man it felt great
felt great